a historic day in American history
you're looking live at the white at the
House floor excuse me as lawmakers get
ready to vote on the impeachment of
President Donald Trump the debate raging
for hours over the articles against the
president and it's all leading to an
eventual vote later tonight Speaker
Nancy Pelosi trying to make the case for
Democrats earlier very sadly now our
founders vision of a republic is under
threat from actions from the White House
that is why today a Speaker of the House
I soundly and sadly opened the debate on
the impeachment of the President of the
United States it is tragic that the
president's reckless actions make
impeachment necessary
he gave us no choice the president is an
ongoing threat to our national security
and the integrity of our elections the
basis of our democracy and Republican
congressman Doug Collins calling out the
Democrats from the very moment that the
majority party in this house won the
inevitability that we would be here
today was only a matter of what date
they would schedule it nothing else in
fact how it even began to be look even
further was on September 24th the
speaker announced an impeachment inquiry
before even seeing the call transcript
that we're gonna hear so much about
today the clock in the calendar of
terrible masters they do not care about
anything except getting the time done
and the calendar fix they do not care
about facts they do not care about time
and one day the clock in the calendar
will hang along this body in a very
detrimental way it's all happening while
President Trump is gearing up for a
rally tonight in Michigan and the
president ripping into Democrats on
Twitter saying such atrocious lies by
the radical left do-nothing Democrats
this is an assault on America and an
assault on the Republican Party with
four exclamation points Jesse four of
them that is a lot and what do you think
about the Democrats all saying they're
very sad and solemn they're not sad the
squad was saying impeach the mf'er and
everyone was cheering about a year ago
and this isn't a solemn day they love it
the saddest part is they're mad because
the polls turned against them we'll get
to that in a second one
when you're holding up a poster as well
like Pelosi is with a flag on it you've
lost the debate you don't need a poster
just listen to what she has to say and
the Democrats talking about they're
doing this for the flag they burn flags
they kneel when the flags go up and
they're talking about the Constitution
when have we ever heard Democrats
strictly adhering to the Constitution
never the whole thing is fake we knew it
a long time ago and that's why as the
cue poll the CNN poll the USA Today poll
the NPR poll the IBD Monmouth n Gallup
all have impeachment underwater one the
Democrats are basically they're drowning
and a flood that they created can I show
the Gallup poll please this has the
president up six points since
impeachment began and so now wants and
Jessie directed so much of that to you I
will turn it over to you
thank you well I mean obviously what you
just saw there was forty five percent of
America and it's about half in most
polls including the Fox poll say he not
only should be impeached but removed
from office as we moved towards
impeachment on this historic day and the
second thing to say is about his
approval what did I miss
no I just I just was interjecting that
the numbers for the president have
improved since impeachment started right
but the point is that the country's
divided Dana but this constant divided
why don't know it's Moda no no the
country when this began back in
September is when we saw the Democrats
in specific and much of the country
suddenly Baltic to close to half of the
country saying based on what they know
the evidence that had been presented
this man should be removed from office
he has abused the power and in terms of
his approval numbers that you said up
like six points to get way again he's
not he's in the mid 40s mid 40s he has
never hit fifty percent and even in
terms of impeachment remember and I keep
saying this Bill Clinton when he was
impeached he was popular he was like 60
percent of approval rating and the
demand for his impeachment was like a
twenty nine percent to the contrary with
Donald Trump it's half the country and
his approval numbers are under fifty
percent okay but
that President Trump is that now is the
same not this the same level that
President Obama had at this point in his
reelection effort do you would you like
to hear from Al Green
well actually I want to talk about the
reality of this okay Trump is not going
anywhere that is why why Pelosi is so
somber because she knows she handed
Schumer an FBOs a flaming bag of
and the more somber the tones are in the
meeting the Dems which by the way
matches perfectly do you notice how CNN
and the Dems are exactly the same somber
tones they make they're exactly the same
they're on the same team but the more
somber they are the bigger the joke they
play on themselves
I don't want to criticize you Dana
because I know you didn't write that
word historic but did what they want you
to believe is that this is historic
right they keep saying oh this is
historic this is historic yes maybe it's
a source but for not for the reasons
that you think it's historic because
it's the first the first impeachment
that is based on future actions they
couldn't find the crime so now they're
saying you got to get him out of office
in case Trump commits a crime okay so
now it's Minority Report the Tom Cruise
movie second the media is never going to
be the same this is historical and
that's awesome because this this whole
process in the last three years has
pulled back the curtain and we see the
media's arrogance their elitism their
bias all together all the lives that
they portray is fact and so when Trump
correctly diagnosed fake news as enemy
of the people now you're seeing it
unfold and this is what's driving them
crazy because it's not going to happen
Trump's gonna remain president he's
gonna probably be reelected using the
very tools that these people thought
they could use against him congressman
Chris Stewart kdl how do you react to
this because it speaks to your point
about this about future actions what
could happen in the future if this is
sound bite number 10 in the control and
you could play Chris Stewart earlier
today
if this impeachment is successful the
next president I promise you is going to
be impeached and the next president
after that if you set this bar as being
impeachable every president in our
future will be impeached erodes our
republic in ways that our founding
fathers
they got it right high crimes and
misdemeanors other than that settle it
at the ballot box I look forward to that
day Katie yeah I mean Democrats always
claim that they are doing this for the
country that they're doing this to
protect democracy as Pelosi said to
uphold the Republic but they're actually
thinking very short-term and this entire
process has shown that they are
completely hypocrites when it comes to
that line that narrative that they take
this is about protecting the vote of the
American people Democrats only care
about democracy when they win but when
there's a Republican who who who wins
they protest there are lots of
protesters out all across the country
today they want to impeach the president
now they're doing it this is like the
fourth time they tried to do this so
let's go back and remember what they
tried to impeach him for earlier now
green for example they tried to impeach
him for criticizing people in the NFL
who kneeled for the flag okay Nancy
Pelosi today seems like you know the
that the national anthem is like a good
thing to now be revering as she's trying
to win this fight they tried to impeach
him for going after the squad they tried
to impeach him for saying bad things
about third-world countries so that
we've been through this before they've
lost all credibility especially in light
of the Russia case putting all their
stake in robert muller and now trying to
put all of this in front of the american
people with no clear compelling evidence
as we'll heard has said all along and
again you know you can look at this and
say maybe the call wasn't perfect as a
presence arguing but we shouldn't be
impeaching him and i find it interesting
that tulsi gabbard as we look ahead
there's a debate tomorrow she was
supposed to be voting today she didn't
show up for the boat and she said that
she's going to introduce a censure
instead of voting for impeachment and
that's we brought up Al Green this is a
congressman who has been calling for
president's impeachment I think since
the first day I mean early early on he's
been wanting this take a listen take a
listen to what he had to say to that
if this president is allowed to throw it
the efforts of Congress with a
legitimate impeachment inquiry the
president will not only be above the law
he will be beyond justice
we cannot allow any person to be beyond
justice in this country in the name of
democracy on behalf of the Republic and
for the sake
of the many who are suffering I will
vote to impeach and I encourage my
colleagues to do so as well if he had a
legitimate case why would he need to
show up with a giant photo of a little
girl that had nothing to do with
impeachment it was also part of a
debunked story about separation if he
was purely confident that he had a case
he wouldn't have need to lie to America
which he has been for quite a while
I think the rage just got the best of
the Democrats if we remember there were
Democrats who refused to certify the
election results there were Democrats
who boycotted the inauguration this
campaign of the president was spied on
they hatched a partisan witch hunt
accused him of being a traitor to the
country of working with the Russians
that was all a hoax and the day that
hoax evaporated with Muller's testimony
bombing they concoct this other fake
whistleblower story and Juan said
something very interesting about the
polls where they were when this whole
thing started in September
I agree the polls were against the
president then but as more people read
the transcript and as more people heard
what the Democrats case was those polls
turned right upside down okay and that's
where we are right here's remain
stagnant
you're saying it's divided but you don't
well I tell the audience about the trend
what about in your favor you everybody
can look okay yes I don't argue audience
knows ou are ridiculously wrong but let
me just say that what you hear from my
colleagues here is a request for you the
audience took one not treated as a
historic day even though this is just
the third US president who's going to be
impeached secondly ignore it it's the
Democrats oh they're so wrong they've
always wanted to enclosure this is the
day it's live that's right for the whole
and we because its historic and because
the Kratt say this history this trunk
made of photo yes
Hall that was about his political
interest not about our increase the
transcript one you know the famous line
when scoundrels call up all their
patriotism its to disguise their columns
that you see is Republicans trying to
divide attention one case Locklear case
of abuse of power by this white history
and when Trump wins re-election he's
going to have a mandate like you've
never seen me say if he's in a second
term after game in a March
if you Democrats ran out of we have a
constitution that says that the
president is not above the law he is one
of us I don't wanna make a point about
the fairness argument because I want you
take a listen to this is soundbite
number four up in a control room so
Katie I think this is the other thing as
people have watched all of this the
issue of fairness has come up over and
over again here's Doug Collins earlier
today the minority leader in the Senate
went out into the press conference said
they denied my witnesses they denied my
request well welcome to the club mr.
Schumer that's exactly what's happened
over here for the last three months
wonder about the Democrats making that
decision right to not to allow witnesses
from the Republicans and now kind of
having to pay a price for and they've
they've given Chuck Schumer really
nowhere to go and they've made his
demands look really silly considering
Adam Schiff wasn't willing to give any
wiggle room to Republicans when we went
through this the first time again
damaging their credibility on the issue
but I think that when the president
talks about due process and fairness
from Republicans talked about it
every day Americans can relate directly
to that they don't want to be falsely
accused of a crime or of doing something
that they did not do or being removed
from a position simply because people
don't like them or have a disagreement
with their policies and that is where I
think Democrats are severely under
estimating the blowback of this next
year and also you know if Democrats
really had a solid argument on this
there wouldn't be Democrats changing
their party to Republican and there
wouldn't be more defections today after
all of the evidence for those been
presented for Democrats to vote
also something that did you guys see
this I don't know how real it is but
it's real enough that it made a lot of
head that was making some headlines just
a couple of hours ago there is a
movement amongst some on the Democratic
side to have Nancy Pelosi not send the
article of impeachment to the Senate
denying the president a trial and the
opportunity to be acquitted what do you
think of that well here's here's the
thing what they've done is they
belittled the the the actual importance
of impeachment right now anybody can do
it so it's like next time and by the way
everybody gets their turn at bat right
so it's gonna happen I think what Trump
has done with impeachment is to his
advantage what seems to be an injury
actually turns into like a badge of
honor it's like this is gonna help
galvanize his base he's probably gonna
win reelection because it is such a
fraud that now be he's like yeah I'm the
oh I'm not not only am I going to be
impeached but I'm gonna be the first
re-elected I'm gonna be re-elected after
impeachment will be a historic day yeah
but here's the here that'll be a sad one
I know you'll agree with me DC style is
in need of improvement okay so here's
the other comedy part of this the 2010
are the greatest decade in the history
probably of the world we're seeing the
greatest economy in history probably the
best year 2019 in our economic modern
history the custodian of that economy in
a time where we're seeing reductions in
disease increase in in in income is
being impeached in the best year in the
best economy in the best decade of the
world the Democrats want to get the
custodian out of the job every decade
that we have experienced has been better
than the last Greg wait better one
no you create you I think that we have
as a human race made tremendous progress
and to suggest that Oh Donald Trump
showed up and the billionaire made it
alright in terms of our economy is that
our money if they ignore what Obama did
and turn they're setting this up because
of Obama let it go I just want to make
when we talk about Democrats there's a
Republican who's gone to Tanzania to
avoid this vote I mean it's ridiculous
that you have
the problem here is Republican blindness
the facts of a real case as they all
know there are the fastest crime he
that's why you're preventing oh you're
doing the peach wit to prevent the
future maybe maybe it's the president's
own transcript of his own phone perfect
sound bite number 12 this is Adam Schiff
and this goes to the thing that you're
talking about that they're impeaching
him for future actions because they're
worried about the 2020 election sound
byte 12th please the timing is driven
more by the fact that the plot continues
if the president is seeking still to
essentially cheat in the next election
that is not a remedy for his misconduct
and the remedy is impeachment and that's
why we've moved forward and we've done
so you know methodically but nonetheless
with a sense of urgency Jesse what do
you think I mean he said that the
president is seeking still to
essentially cheat in the next election
it's a lie just like they're lying about
Trump cheating in the last election
people lie because they can't accept the
truth and the truth is the Democrats
lost in 2016 and they're gonna win
they're gonna lose again in 2020 they're
protecting their own base from going
crazy because they need to send it
poison to keep it calm because right now
it's crazy and that's why we got
impeachment in the first place none of
these clowns can beat the president and
that's why they're trying to pre impeach
him this is just a short circuit of
dividers let's go and to say that Donald
Trump gets credit for Barack Obama's
economy is nonsense okay you know that
let predicted he'd crash the economy
so which economy is it okay a couple
months ago when there was gonna be a
recession Trump was blamed and now stock
market records are being smashed and
it's Obama's let's just go to the facts
for a second and stop with the rhetoric
I mean the facts are the facts Jesse and
the rhetoric that's not rhetoric the
fact is a faction of the family Giuliani
continues to travel over the Ukraine
trying to collect information on the
president's likely opponent Joe Biden
and you say oh there's no threat for the
president cheating again so what buying
up to do it
he wants over-seasoned we can't Joe
Biden has his lawyer family know about
it this is Republican blindness on
display for the 500k Hillary Clinton
literally paid for foreign involvement
in the 2016 election by paying a company
a firm that was using a foreign spy to
get information from Russian sources to
be used by the FBI to go after a
presidential candidate was were to win
what she didn't she would have had to be
impeached over that because that is far
worse than anything that the president
said in his phone call but back to Adam
Schiff real quickly that is what he said
is a perfect example of claiming to
protect democracy while completely
undermining it and accusing the
president falsely of things that he did
not do you have you have Jerry Nadler
saying we can't trust the next election
to decide or fix the problem so if this
is happening in a foreign country in a
democracy where power supposed to be
peacefully transferred the State
Department would be issuing condemnation
of the behavior of the opposing party
and yet here we are with the continuing
this narrative when they are attacking
and don't forget the Democrats could
come back to this well over and over
again until the election you can peach
more than once if they wanted to do that
right